cada día se escuchan explosiones en
territorio sudanés pese a las múltiples
treguas los choques entre los militares
y los paramilitares no se detienen y los
intentos de los ciudadanos por huir
tampoco los nacionales de países como
Estados Unidos Reino Unido o Francia
fueron evacuados principalmente en
aviones pero la travesía ha sido
diferente para ciudadanos de otros
países de África o para los udaneses
algunos logran abandonar el país por mar
otros por vía terrestre en un viaje de
casi 1000 km hasta la frontera con
Egipto en el exterior Ya no hay combates
pero la lucha continúa
la gente llega cansada duermen en las
calles en las mezquitas en las escuelas
las llevamos en microbús y las dejamos
temprano los buses están llenos los
pasos fronterizos están congestionados
estas personas por fin llegaron a abulla
la capital nigeriana
experiencia que nunca imaginé porque es
una situación que nunca pensé enfrentar
en mi vida
despertaba cada mañana en medio de
disparos bombas y el lugar donde
vivíamos está cerca de barricadas
Naciones Unidas alertó de una catástrofe
humanitaria ya son más de 100.000 las
personas que han abandonado el país y la
cifra podría aumentar hasta unas 800.000
el organismo Indicó que se necesitan 445
millones de dólares para atender a
quienes Huy